immigration on the agenda Secretary of
State blinkin and DHS secretary myor is
heading to Mexico for a high stakes
meeting with Mexico's president orador
it was a record Christmas by the way at
the border with more than 35,000
migrants Crossing illegally over the
4-day holiday weekend and more than
730,000 since October 1st our next guest
says Biden's policies are to blame
National border patrol council president
Brandon Jud joining us Brandon let's go
right to this meeting now it's going to
be blinkin my orcus and the White
House's sort of Border National Security
advisor Liz Sherwood Randall but if you
were there what would you say to orador
what would be your
Insight the first thing that we have to
look at is is you used a phrase Fool's
errand a little earlier and that's
exactly what this is going to be we're
we're setting ourselves up for failure
because we're expecting another country
to fix our problems and they're never
going to do it it all comes down to
incentive does the Mexican Government
have incentive to stop this illegal
immigration that's taking place and they
don't because they're they're generating
billions of dollars for their own
economy so if I were there I would look
at you know what is it that that they
could do to help us and why would they
want to um but my fear right now is is
that they're going to try to extract
concessions from us whether that's in
monetary whether that's easing um
sanctions on Venezuela there's a lot of
different things that Mexican government
wants us to do so they're going to try
to extract those concessions for them to
be true border security partners and
that just doesn't help us we've got to
look at what the solutions are right
here in the United States we have those
Solutions this Administration just
doesn't want to to exercise their
authority to stop this you know Brandon
it's interesting the leader of this
Caravan you're looking at Luis viagran
he said to a reporter that's following
it that this meeting talking about the
blinking my orcus and overdoor meeting
will quote be between fools and fools
who want to use women and children as
trading pieces we are not trading pieces
what Mexico wants is money and that's
essentially what you're saying and
that's ex go ahead that that's exactly
what they want that they do want money
the Mexican Government wants to generate
profit they want their economy to
succeed and if you look at the cartels
the cartels are generating billions of
dollars for the Mexican economy so all
of this chaos that we see that's hurting
our country is helping The Mexican
government and so that's the reason why
they're not going to become true border
security Partners I have to go back to
the Trump Administration look at what is
it that they did right and what they did
was they threatened tariffs that were
greater than the amount of money that
these cartels were able to bring in and
that's why Mexico during the Trump era
was was willing to actually step to the
plate and do what was necessary to stop
all of this illegal immigration through
their own country but unless we're
willing to give them something we're
they're not going to do anything or
unless we come from a position of power
and that's what I don't think that blink
and my orc is going to do I do not
believe that they are going to come with
the big stick and tell them if you don't
do something we're going to start uh
using our power to to go back and and
force you to to become true border
security Partners there's just no
incentive for the Mexican Government to
do anything that's such an important
Point Brandon the big stick is bringing
back remain in Mexico which migrants
don't like and that's why they stopped
coming in economic consequences on
Mexico for not doing anything about it
but if the administration if myor and
blinkin are not willing to bring that
big stick what's the point of this
meeting there is no point but so let let
me take that back the point is is the
Optics here in the United States and the
mainstream media the mainstream media is
always going to give them a pass as long
as they they show that they're trying to
do something uh but in reality again
let's go back to that phrase It's a
Fool's errand this Administration knows
that by sending them down there they're
going to get the mainstream media to say
oh look look they're doing something
they're doing something when in reality
nothing is going to change unless we
force them to become true border
security Partners or unless this
Administration uses the authority that
they have right now to secure the border
on our side of the Border National
border patrol council president Brandon
Jud always great Insight from you
Brandon and we will see what happens in
this meeting and talk about it and see
if it does anything to knock down this
unprecedented surge that we've never
seen at our border Brandon thank you
very
much thank you Griff I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis